now good evening and thank you for
joining us tonight at 6 30. i'm sasha
loftis that wind is making its way into
the valley and it could get dangerous
tomorrow let's go ahead and start with
sally jeremiah with a look at what we
can expect here sally yes sasha that
high wind watch has been upgraded to a
high wind warning this is showing you
that red area there southern clark
county barstow definitely going to be
impacted our spring mountains indian
springs and perum officially kicking in
tomorrow at 11 a.m going all the way
into that tuesday morning 3 a.m start
right behind it we're also tracking some
strong gusts but we're officially
tracking a wind advisory for the lakes
for moapa valley where they're going to
be noticing those gusts up to 40 to 55
miles per hour the strongest gusts
appearing for southern clark county
possibly up to 50 to 70 miles per hour
outside right now plenty of low 70s and
wind speeds you could see it there
remaining pretty calm and quiet at this
hour but officially that's all about to
change starting tomorrow
strongest winds look to arrive for the
nighttime hours this evening we do
expect to remain on the clear side north
northwest winds will stay 5 miles per
hour with temperatures dropping to 61
degrees by 11 p.m coming up much more to
talk about strong spring storm system
will bring us all those changes
widespread high winds to the region
blowing dust followed by cooler
conditions over to you
and continuing that team coverage
tonight to keep you prepared and safe
from those strong winds madison
kimbrough spoke with hardware store
shoppers this afternoon on what they
plan to do she joins us near decatur and
tropicana
many people say with the high ones we're
expecting for tomorrow getting the
essentials ahead of time is a must with
high wind gusts of 55 to 70 miles per
hour expected to push through the valley
the potential for property damage is of
high concern simple tips such as
securing items outside your home if you
have one make sure to place your car in
your garage and of course keep your pets
indoors at all times we spoke to some
hardware store shoppers on what they've
seen and how they plan to prepare make
sure all the doors and stuff are closed
you don't want nothing to slam
blinds will
go crazy panels for units if they're not
tied down they'll blow off and they
could crash out on a car or something so
while it may be tempting to try to fix a
light or downed wire around your house
do not attempt to make any repairs until
the severe weather has calmed down we
reached out to envy energy for comment
as they issued an alert earlier this
morning about downed power lines stating
that crews will be ready to respond as
soon as possible reporting near
tropicana decatur madison kimbrough live
local now